[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى موجز الي اهم الانباء التامه
رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان
رئيس الحكومه وزير الداخليه وقائدا كبيرا
في الاستخبارات بالتخطيط الاغتياله ودعا
في اول ظهور له منذ محاوله اغتياله مؤيديه
للخروج وتظاهر ضد مسماه الحكومه المستورده
رفض الجيش الباكستانيه
وعبر وزير الداخليه الباكستانيه عن اسفه
لتحميل لحزب انصافه الحكومه مسؤوليه
الاعتداء ولم يحل احتمال تورطي عناصر
دينيه متطرفه
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمي بوتين على اهميه
اجلاء السكان المدنيين في خرسون من
المناطق الاكثر خطوره وقد تراجعت موسكو عن
فرض حظر تجوال في المدينه بعد دقائق من
اعلانه وقالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
دفاعات جيشها اسقطت صاروخين روسيين من
طراز كاليبر في ميكو لايف
الجنوبيه مقاتله بعضها من طراز الشبح ردا
على اجراء ممثل من كوريا الشماليه كما
اكدت سهول ان طائرات المشاركه في مناورات
عسكريه مع الولايات المتحده ايضا على
جاهزيتها وقد حذرت من المناورات وطلبت
بايقافها
افادت بكالوريا رويترز نقلا عن كالتي ينهب
ان القوات الجويه الامريكيه تخطط لنقل
القرنفل استراتيجيه بي وان بي اليوم السبت
المشاركه في المناورات العسكريه المشتركه
بين الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
عقد مجلس الامن الدولي جلسه لبحث في
تحركات كوريا الشماليه بعد عمليات اطلاق
الصواريخ باتجاه كوريا الجنوبيه
في المجلس اطلاقا بيوم بيانغ الصواريخ
الاخيره ولمحت الى قيام الصين وروسيا
بتوفير الحمايه لها في مجلس الامن
افادت وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه بان منصه
تويتر سرحت نحو 50 في المئه من موظفيها او
توقع ان يصل عدد الذين سيتم تسريحهم
3,700 موظف كانت صحيفه اول لذكر الله
علقت اعلاناتها في تويتر وقالت انها
ستراقب توجهات مصر في تويتر قبل العوده
الى تويتر شهيدا انخفاضا هائلا في
الايرادات بسبب تراجع عائلات الاعلانات
وفي تعليق له على صفقه الاستحواذ على
تويتر نقلت رويترز عن الرئيس الامريكي
اشترى منصه
وتنفذ الاكاذيب في ارجاء العالم
نهايه الموجز شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]